yeah well you know i i don't think it's
i
i think at the core of it what i've
learned in in my few years
and as an investor is to always just
remember we're human first
and no matter how many rules or what
best practices you practice
we all have off days on both sides
but that is not to excuse any of
the systematic challenges that we have
in our industry
that do relate to favoring
a homogeneous group of people and
and marginalizing
[Music]
founders that can indeed build great
companies i mean one of the things that
really upsets me is
that often times when i've presented a
deal
to an investor who's more of a
traditional investor that's that's
that's what i call traditional um
they'll say oh that's nice
is this for charity is this and
and and so there is this other aspect of
even beyond the in rudeness and a pitch
there is this consideration that as soon
as you are a woman
or a woman of color or just a person of
color or just a
underestimated founder that sometimes
just by default
the first thought that comes out in in
somebody's mind and i've had this happen
with in conversations with other
investors
is oh that's nice oh that's a smb
business or what is this hair product
thing or what is
because because the markets are not
understood but you know if you
if you step back and think about how we
are i mean
gen z's already minority majority
population
you start to see that having a
homogeneous outlook on life is not going
to pan out in the long term
and and it's really important to to
appreciate
diverse founders for the edge in
business
and perspective that they that they
provide a market that's evolving into
something that is is not homogeneous
anymore
um yeah it was uh
very interesting for us uh
when we tried to increase the number of
underrepresented founders um
that we were meeting in order to invest
our free events didn't um
really help we were doing these free
events and we still saw a very
low number of people of color applying
and
i guess you know you could say okay well
you did a free event and not many people
applied
we did the best we could and then what
we challenged ourselves
internally uh was to do an event just
for underrepresented founders
and when we did that the number of
applications went through the roof
when we asked people why they came to
this event and not other ones
they said when i saw you doing this
founder university for women or founding
university for underrepresented founders
jason
jackie who runs it um i realized that
you were really committed to this
and therefore i applied because i knew
you were taking it seriously
and i should give it my attention so i
think creating spaces for these founders
um to have you know a hundred percent of
the energy in the room has been a
breakout for us i don't know if anybody
else can
um benefit from that but if you're not
seeing enough
deal flow you have to ask yourself like
maybe people don't feel like contacting
you you know that's like a
that's a real phenomenon as well right i
mean you just saw angela say
you know i'm gonna watch where i put my
money where i take my money right
and other other founders are saying the
same thing and authenticity in this game
right now is
is real and that is going to be i'm
seeing it be more and more of the
currency
what are you saying what are you doing
where are you writing your checks and
what does your team look like
i have had several vcs
big names call me and ask me what do i
do
and i said it's pretty simple look at
your team
hire people that are representative of
the deal flow that you want
and make it real don't make it some sort
of statement that's for pr
and marketing and hope that the fad
blows over
because i don't think that that is what
is happening anymore i do think that
there's a lot of stickiness
to what is happening now yeah it does
feel like this is a tipping point
uh in culture you know we've never seen
anything like this
uh in terms of the number of people
protesting it's really eye-opening
um and then people demanding change